do you think the things we build today
will be considered wonders in the future
think of Stonehenge the pyramids Machu
Picchu and Easter Island now they're all
pretty different from what we're doing
today with those massive stones
assembled in complex but seemingly
illogical ways and all traces of their
construction erased shrouding them in
mystery it seems like people could not
have possibly built these things because
people didn't they were carefully
crafted by a primordial race of giants
known as Cyclops and I've been
collaborating with these monsters to
learn their secrets for moving those
massive stones and as it turns out
Cyclops aren't even that strong they're
just really smart about getting material
to work for them now the videos you see
behind me of large stone like wobbly
creatures are the results of this
collaboration
okay so Cyclops might be a mythical
creature but those wonders are still
real people made them but they also made
the myths that surround them when it
comes to wonders there's this thick
connective tissue between mythology and
reality take Easter Island for example
when the Dutch explorers first
encountered the island they asked the
people of Rapa Nui how their ancestors
could have possibly moved those massive
statues and the Rapa Nui said our
ancestors didn't move the statues
because the statues walked themselves
for centuries this was dismissed but
actually it's true
the statues known as moai were
transported standing pivoting from side
to side
okay as spectacular as the moai are for
visitors today
you have to imagine being there then
with colossal moai marching around the
island because the real memorial was not
the objects themselves
it was the cultural ritual of bringing a
stone to life so as an architect I've
been chasing that dream how can we shift
our idea of construction to accommodate
that mythical side so what I've been
doing is challenging myself with putting
on a series of performances of the
ancient but pretty straightforward task
of just moving and standing big heavy
objects like this 16-foot tall megalith
designed to walk across land and stand
vertically or this four thousand-pound
behemoth that Springs itself to life to
dance on stage and what I found is that
by thinking of architecture not as an
end product but as a performance from
conception to completion we end up
rediscovering some really smart ways to
build things today you know so much of
the discussion surrounding our future
focuses on technology efficiency and
speed but if I've learned anything from
Cyclops that said wonders can be smart
spectacular and sustainable because of
their mass and their mystery and while
people still want to know how those
ancient wonders were built I've been
asking Cyclops how to create the mystery
that compels people to ask that very
question because in an era where we
design buildings to last 30 maybe 60
years
I would love to learn how to create
something that could entertain for an
eternity thank you
[Applause]